HON TO
POWER AND IN THEA TRUMP SUPPORTE
RTTHE RI
BED WHY HE CAME HE A
>>ASICALLY PUTUT, YOU O ST.
YOU KNOW
I NEEDED TO BE DOWRE. TRUMP PUT
IT. LICHNS
D MAN.DENT TRUMPS
S NOT AN IMPRESSIOBL
>> MEANWHILE TRUMP A
ISNGHAECIDED
E QUOTE BIDE ANNOUNCE FO
R THM ECISSI
WORLD?
SEEMS EVERYBODY IS PUSHING HIM
P  IT IS THE  TO ANOR SN'T MATTE
AFTER LABOR DAY.Y POINT THIS SME
KNOW WANS ENGEAND  FROM THFIRSTS
CONFERENCES. HAVE ALLIES ON TMMN
NOT SATUTI THE A WAVES
WI DEFENSES OFLF.
THE SECONDS TO PUTT HI
ON NOTICE.
KNOTH IPOTENTIALLY GOING TO BEN
2024 A TG THONER TRE
ANWAS THE PLANGA HIM
OU
AND THE THIRD TO H
CAPI ON THBIDEPU
PERSONALITY. >> WE HAVE THEMP R
HESE
POCA AA CANDIDATE
OM AIELD.
CAN SEE WHY.ISJ  LOOKING INTO JU
6, MISHANG OCL HE PRO
WHY RE T HARY IT ANE
EW LARGE POINTS
NNIN EASIER R HIM
TO SAY THIS IS POLITICAL, ALL
HU.  ABSOLUTELY.I WOD ADD A NU
I KNOCK LAHAVING FLASH BACKS TOI
INITIAL STAGES OF IS HE GOING TO
RUN IND SORTFALLING INTOAME TRA
COVERING EVERYE HE IS
WE KNOW HE IS GO LSO HE IS VERMS
PREVIEL  NEXT
RUMP SHOW.OV FACUTS HIM IN THE
EVERY TIME IK TO WORRIED HWA O .
REPUBLICAN VOTER
U
TRUMP COME BACK.T NEARLY AS IT
A WOMAN  PYL HE
CAN HAVE THE PERSONALITY AND
>> BK IN WASHINGTON GRAH
ID TS  "THE WASHINGTON
POST."
IF STRUN IT WILL
UTURE. AVE LESSTION.
IS VANCE?
I DO WONDER WHAT ETRAIGN WOULD
THE FIGURE ID
N ISD J.
HIM INAY THE
IF THEIDCT DRMPB
HE WILL GET E ATTENTION THAT
MITCLL BE BUT OW I
DBOUT C ASTHAHEIT IS ALL ABOUTA
BELIEVE THCO
PRETTYL.
TR -- PANGT WHAT
AND ACTIONS
WERE AND DURING THE MOMEOFE INS
E  TS VERY CEN
ABLE TCONNECT THE DOTHE
TRUMP ACTIONS WO THE
AC RIOTERS' ACTIONS.
E COORDINATION BETWEEN THE
JUIC AND
JANUARCOMMITEM B
LE BI